يهنئ زعيمه كوريا الشماليه بانضمام بلاده
للمجلس التنفيذي للصحه العامه التهنئه لم
تمر بسلام على الرئيس السابق فعاصفه من
الانتقادات الحاده هبت بوجهه مصدرها
منافسوه الجمهوريون
نائب ترامب السابق قال انه لا ينبغي لاحد
ان يمدحور كوريا الشماليه يجب ان نوضح
للعالم اننا ندافع عن الحريه ونقف الى
جانب من يدافعون عنها اما التي شغلت في
السابق منصبه حاكمه ولايه ساف كارولاينا
وسفيره لدى الامم المتحده فقالت نحن لا
نهنئ سفاحا هدد امريكا وحلفائها وطبعا
ديسانس لم يترك الفرصه تفلت من يديه وعبر
عن صدمته لرؤيه التهنئه ووصف كيم جونغ اون
بالديكتاتور القاتل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات